i i think mannerism technically
qualifies as a sims-ism mannerism but i
was just going to say that
aneurysm
maybe i've had it wrong for 55 years
peter
now i think you might have had it right
uh i think as a matter of fact i admire
your mannerisms
let's get to it which doesn't belong and
why we had clips there from the coaches
the jaguars lions and jets which doesn't
belong and why in the teams that peter
king has ranked number 29 number 30 and
31 respectively
i'd say probably the detroit lions
because i think they're going to bite
enough kneecaps to maybe climb out of
that that end of the power rankings
whole
um the one guy who doesn't get talked
about very much um bill parcells has
always been really really high on aaron
glenn's ability as a coach so he becomes
a defensive coordinator in detroit and i
think he's going to instill a toughness
if you're not tough under aaron glenn
somebody else is going to be playing and
i think
whereas it was obvious that the lions
many of the lions got tired of the
message that matt patricia had i don't
think they're going to get tired of the
aaron glenn message he's going to be
very much pro player
but he's also going to be extremely
demanding um i i would take detroit as
uh better than number 30 overall
i'm fascinated by the kneecap biting
culture because it's you know the lines
have been so bad for so long you just
roll the dice roll the dice every few
years eventually they're gonna come up
seven when seven is good sometimes seven
is bad eventually they're going to get a
good seven for the detroit lions i'm
gonna say the jaguars don't belong
because they are the latest team to go
all in with the grand experiment of
taking a highly successful college coach
and seeing if it translates will he be
jimmy johnson will it be chip kelly we
don't know but recent recent history
suggests that these college coaches have
their work cut out for them next one
peter
which doesn't belong in y middle of the
pack chargers 10 dolphins 11 cardinals
14 non-playoff teams who made it into
your top 15 which doesn't belong and why
i would say uh the cardinals because
i really really struggle with the
cardinals as much as any team i didn't
love what they did in free agency
because they're trying to create the
2016 all protein
you know and i so i'm not sure how much
free agency is going to help them but
just remember this was an explosive team
for much of last year that really failed
down the stretch so i think the
cardinals have a good chance to be
better than 14.
and look i've got a chance i'm going to
say the cardinals because
the wheels have essentially fallen off
for them since that hail murray game
against the bills the bills went one way
the cardinals went the other this is
cliff kingsbury's proven year and i know
there's this sense he's tied to the hip
with kyler murray but i think at some
point michael bidwell the owner of the
team starts thinking hey we've got this
special young quarterback
maybe maybe we need to be finding a way
to get more out of him and get more wins
from him
uh you know while we still have him on a
low value contract last one which
doesn't belong in y from number 15
washington number 18 titans and number
19 steelers
i really struggled putting the titans 18
look i don't like i wrote my column i
can't unsee what the steelers became at
the end of the year i have no idea what
their offensive line is going to be i
don't know what matt canada is going to
be like as an offensive coordinator i
just think they're a total mystery team
but the titans
i don't know i put him at 18 and i went
to bed on sunday night and i said man
you're going to look stupid when they
win 11 games again so i mean the titans
at 18
bug me
i just think that they might be without
their court losing both coordinators in
the last two years
they had they struggled to replace dean
p's last year they fell defensively and
now know arthur smith we'll see what the
results are
i'm going to say steelers at 19 because
i think they're going to be better than
that my experience and i've lived near
in or around pittsburgh all my life
when the thinking is they're not going
to be very good they find a way to will
themselves to a surprisingly good season
and mike tomlin very good at getting the
absolute best out of the guys he have
the key though is number one ben
roethlisberger staying healthy number
two naji harris being the real deal for
them all right that's it for which
doesn't belong and why
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports